- [Host] Before I start the Q&A,
I'm gonna make Gary sign my book.
(laughs)
Because even though we've
been friends for a long time,
who knows when he whisks away in his car.
So, quick story, and I don't
know if Gary knows this
but we had the fortune of
I had the fortune of meeting Gary at
a few conferences, early days,
probably early 2000s.
What year was the lobby
was it '03, '02 roughly when we met?
- I think '08.
Actually, '08.
- Okay.
And here's my quick story.
And we're gonna get to Q&A, was
it was cocktail hour, we were in Hawaii,
nice place, lots of people walking around,
it's 6 o'clock, 7 o'clock, it's gorgeous.
We kinda go into a bar.
Being here for three days is not enough.
We need to leave this place
and go to our own island and
go to our own destination
for a fuckin' month!
And I remember hearing
that and being like,
god, this guy's nuts.
This is crazy, and who knows what the
other people around him,
I've never told you this story,
were thinking but my reason
for sharing that story is
I think that says everything, right?
Here's kind of a
with conviction, to convince people
to leave and live some place for a month.
Doesn't matter if it was two weeks
or a month or two months.
But the point was, he was dead serious.
This is an ineffective way for us
to get to know each other.
He kinda pointed me and said,
"for example, Chris Cunningham,
"we don't really know each other."
And my point is, for all the students,
all the kids over there,
that the fearlessness
and ideas that are crazy,
those are the best ones!
Those are the best ones.
So, I think that was
my kind of catalyst to
get to know Gary and kinda
watching what he's doing now.
So, I'm not gonna do
the bio or his intro or
I think what you guys know,
we're gonna get into the Q&A.
'Cause that's what we're here to do.
Okay?
And I get to sit next to
- [Gary] Closer?
- Closer
But I will do one kick off
question to break the ice.
- Okay.
- Wow we're super tight.
Has anyone ever sat this close?
Damn.
- I feel super awesome about it.
- This feels really good.
Hittin' the weights.
Okay, so number one question, Gary.
- Yes.
- We got a lot of high schools in here.
And I want to know, we want to know,
what were you like in high school, man?
What was the Gary V at that time
before this Gary V arrived?
- So, it's funny.
This is interesting timing.
For only a week or two ago I posted my
high school report card on Instagram.
Because I was starting to realize
through a lot of the feedback
that people that were consuming my content
didn't realize when I was saying
that I was a D and F
student in high school,
that I was a D and F student.
I would see a lot of people
reference B's and C's,
which I guess, to
straight A student culture
seems like D's and F's.
I had a very unique high school career.
Number one, when I started high school,
the summer before in eighth grade
was when my Dad dragged
me into the liquor store.
And I basically stopped
hanging out with friends
in eighth grade.
So every summer day of that vacation
leading up to high school,
and every weekend in high school, I worked
at the store.
And I mean, just so everybody knows,
not checking the box,
like you want your kid to work.
More like, because I'm
first generation immigrant.
More like, the merchants
of the '50s and '60s.
Meaning, on Saturday,
I left my house at 7am,
and we got home at 9pm.
And on Sunday we left at
10am and got home at 6.
Just worked.
And so that's number one, number two,
I am unbelievably, I see a lot of faces,
a lot of people have some context for me.
I am unbelievably not comfortable
being mean to another person.
Just completely does
not come natural to me.
I hate negativity.
I hate cynicism.
And I definitely hate suppressing somebody
or hurting their feelings.
So I was very awkward for high school
where that is of culture,
and so I was awfully friendly
with a lot of people.
It wasn't that I was so
popular with everybody,
it's just that I really genuinely
wanted to be friends with everybody.
Third, I was trying to sell so much shit
to my friends in high school.
Like I would literally take all of lunch
freshman and sophomore year,
and literally walk table to table
trying to sell people baseball cards.
Which wasn't necessarily the
coolest fuckin' thing to do,
but very much kind of where I was
as a person.
And then finally, I
would say the last thing
that sums me up in high school was
we had a Senior breakfast.
I don't know,
I never really heard of
this but our high school
thought it was a tradition.
Somewhere in March or April with
maybe a month or two left in high school,
the whole Senior class got together
in the cafeteria and they
did a nice breakfast.
And then they gave out mics
for people to say things.
And not a lot of people
wanted to say things
or sappy things.
And I'll never forget, my one friend
took the mic and he goes,
"the number one thing I'll
remember about high school
"is always being super
hopeful that Gary Vaynerchuk
"was in my class, 'cause I knew that meant
"that he was gonna distract the teacher
"from between seven and 15 minutes a day
"and we would end up not working as hard
"in that class."
(audience laughs)
So that was me.
- So, any of those people in this room
that distracter?
Yeah.
Alright, so I have more questions,
I will fill in gaps as needed.
But this is about everyone
in here in the room,
in particular, the students, so
one thing, one quick rule.
Quick questions, maybe
not too many follow ups.
And we'll keep it flowin'
so everyone can kind of
get in as much as possible
while Gary is with us, right?
- You got the mic over there?
- The microphone's right over there,
if you want to walk over so we
can hear you loud and clear.
Maybe as that first brave
person's walking over,
just maybe hello, your name, and
I know most of the questions are gonna be
directed for me but I really encourage you
to ask Gary.
(laughs)
- Hey man.
- [Martin] Hey Gary, big fan.
- Thank you, what's your name?
- [Martin] Martin.
- Martin
- [Martin] Martin,
on the associate board like
a couple of these people are here.
I listen to your podcast
and one of the themes
that I get is that you've taught people
that you wouldn't be where you are today
unless you made big, bold moves
to put yourself out there.
And you see what happens.
And so, this is for the first time,
a lot of the students in the room here
are trying that out in the program.
And so sometimes they
don't get what they want
after they put themselves out.
So, I wanted to ask you,
can you tell us about a time when you
put yourself out there,
and didn't get what you wanted,
and how you dealt with it?
- That's a good question.
Jesus.
The reason I said Jesus is
it's unbelievable how much I struggle
with recalling failures,
even though I have failures every day.
And so I'm trying to be
empathetic to the students
and think about something
that would bring them value.
Here's my thing.
I'm gonna take your question,
and I'm gonna try to provide value,
which is the following.
I'm curious who gets to own a loss.
I'm curious, when I put myself out there,
the biggest mistakes
I've made in my career,
hands down, have been
the things I didn't do,
versus what I've done.
I'm an old school immigrant.
I seem aggressive in
putting myself out there,
I'm ridiculously practical.
I've never put myself
in any kind of position
that has ever made me super vulnerable
to lose it.
I've never bet it all, right?
We took a huge mortgage
in building Wine Library.
That was kind of betting it all,
but I was, as long as I was healthy,
I was running that business.
To me the bigger question here is,
when you fail, when you do a start up,
and you fail, right?
Who gets to own that loss?
Is the much more interesting question that
I would tell all the kids here,
which is when you fail, when you do this
and nobody buys your hats,
who owns that?
I think I own it.
My L's are my L's.
Your two cents on my losses
don't mean shit to me.
And I think the biggest
reason people struggle
with doing things, is they
allow somebody else's opinion
matter more than their
own about themselves.
And so when I curse, or when
I have made bold predictions
or all the things that I've done
some of the, all those fancy
people at those conferences
that I met in 2000 when
I started VaynerMedia,
they called me and said they
were disappointed in me.
This is real life.
That whole crew of all the founders
who built trillion dollar companies
who would listen to me and
thought I was thoughtful
a decade ago,
called me when I started
VaynerMedia and said that
they were disappointed
in me because I could do
so much more than just build an agency.
I respected that because
these were the characters
that were building Facebook and Dropbox
and Uber, and I had empathy!
But I also have self-awareness.
I wasn't gonna build
one of those companies.
It's not how I'm wired, it's
not how I create wealth,
I knew that I was gonna eat
crow for a decade or two,
build a platform foundation
and then I would buy companies
and run them through it, and
that over a 30 year period,
I could create entrepreneurial success and
massive building growing.
So when you have the fanciest, hottest,
I literally at the time had three people
on the covers of Forbes
and Ink and Fast Company
call me and say, you
basically, in a nice way,
you suck.
And for me, I just loved
it because I couldn't wait.
And by the way, I just mentioned three
that went on to crush it.
I had eight or nine others
who raised 40 million
for their fancy products and they lost.
And they have jobs now.
And so, you don't know who's going to
do what.
My big thing is, for
the kids in this crowd,
when you do something,
when you go back to school
and nobody bought your hats
and they make fun of you,
I just don't understand
what the value of their opinion is.
Because I know that you got
the experience of understanding
why did they or not buy the hats.
- Love it, thank you.
(applauding)
Yeah we'll take some applause.
That's great.
(audience applauding)
You got a question?
Yeah, he's ready.
- My name is
and I was wondering, how do you stand out
in a society saturated with media?
- I think it's depth.
I think it's quality.
People always ask me how do I stand out,
how do I grow awareness,
how do I get more followers,
all the cliche stuff.
It's always gonna come
down to having the chops.
I was just being interviewed
before I went up here
and the young man says,
how do I get to be where you are, quickly?
And I said to him, you don't.
(laughs)
I think the thing that is
often forgotten in my narrative
is I did work for 15
years building businesses
before I ever spoke about it
or wrote a book or gave a speech.
And I think right now, I don't
look down on the youngsters
trying to build a brand or stand out
because I'm sure if I had the internet
at this stage when I was 16,
I would have gravitated
towards it with my personality,
I have empathy.
The problem is, the only way to stand out,
in my opinion, is to stand
out for the long term.
You can do a lot of things to stand out
for the next week.
You can use shock movement,
you can growth hack,
you can buy followers,
all the dumb shit that everybody's doing
to win for a week or a
month, maybe even a year.
To me, the question is how
do you stand out forever?
And that's being a tortoise, not a hare.
That's doing the right
thing day in and day out.
That's deploying patience, and recognizing
the only people that you
want to be that stand out
are the ones that are
doing something of depth
and that takes a long time to create.
And so that, I think
about standing out from
one simple standpoint
which is having skills,
and executing against them.
The thing you at 15 and
the people here at 70
still have 30, 40 years to go,
they need to figure out self-awareness.
Standing out is a byproduct of you being
self aware and understanding
what you're good at
and what you love and that paradigm,
and then deploying
patience on the execution
of that delta.
That's how you stand out.
- And Gary, when you
mentioned earlier with the
agency model, did you know at that,
it makes perfect sense.
You have a platform,
you build on top of it.
Did you know the path at that time?
Or did you at the time know,
hey I'm gonna disrupt agencies, obviously
you've been in the game.
The codes are ripe for disruption.
- I knew at that time.
I knew, you know what happened
during those summer nights
in Vegas or other conferences I went to
where I was spending a
lot of time with special
kids that I thought were
gonna change the world
and clearly have?
I eat my own dog food,
I was deploying self awareness.
And after a little while
of spending time with
special people, I said, you know what?
What makes them special,
that doesn't make me special?
What makes me special that
doesn't make them special?
I realized at some point
that my ability to understand
human psychology and human nature
and what they would pay
attention to in the future
was something I was trading on.
I understood consumer behavior
a hair of a second faster
than a lot of people
and I had the humility to put in the work
in new places, taste them, and
then be able to trade on it.
So basically what VaynerMedia
is and was at the time
was I going to build the scalable version
of my core one unique strength,
which is communicating in this new world.
- And just to say the way I heard is
you knew your superpower early.
And everyone here has a superpower, right?
- Yeah and everybody's
superpowers are different, right?
Spider-Man's way cooler than Ant-Man.
- There isn't an Ant-Man, is there?
- Yeah there's an Ant-Man!
Dude, what the fuck?
(audience laughs)
And so, to me, the reason I said that is
I don't think everybody's destined to
build a trillion dollar company and
change the world.
And by the way, nor do I think
most people aspire to it,
especially when they
get the taste of being
the last line of defense.
You said something earlier,
we need more entrepreneurship.
I would argue at this
moment, right this second,
we need less entrepreneurship.
And I know that's a curveball.
We need more self awareness.
Everybody thinks they're a founder.
There's a whole lot of executives,
there's a whole lot of people that are
leaving a lot of happiness in their lives
because they're graduating from Morton
and think they're a founder.
But instead what they would have been
is a great number three
or a great number seven.
Please do not
please excuse me, don't
misunderstand this.
The makeup of a number one,
a person who lives their life every day
knowing they're the last line of defense,
and has to have a constant running energy
in the back of their mind
of anxiety of knowing
they are the last line of defense.
And that, you know
what's great about school
and working at some
working somewhere,
you can blame someone else if it fails!
When you start your own
company, when it fails,
it's a hundred percent your fault.
A hundred.
You hired that person.
You made that strategy
during this economic time.
It is 100 percent your fault.
And so, I think we need
more self awareness of
who you are.
And that is something that
I very much believe in.
- Thank you, Gary.
Let's get the next question over there,
microphone in the middle.
And in case you guys are wondering,
right there in the middle.
- [Gary] We'll get him next.
- You mentioned empathy, empathy,
empathy.
- [Gary] Yes.
- There's very few businessmen like you,
your success that it
mentioned empathy so often.
Why is it, where does it come from?
And why is that part of your mojo?
- I think it's gonna be
something in five to seven years
you'll hear most business
people talk about.
I think empathy for me speaks about
a lot of things.
I think it comes from
my mother, to be frank.
I think DNA-wise, and
she also nourished it.
Early on in my life,
I showed a lot of compassion to others.
Back to how I mentioned earlier,
I don't like when people are upset.
So, my Mom would
she would be very aggressive
in making a big deal
when I was kind or
empathetic or compassionate.
Later, I got to spend a
lot of time with my dad.
We lived 45 minutes away
from the liquor store.
So we would drive up Route
78 in Jersey back and forth.
My dad doesn't talk.
He's just an old school, eastern European,
we are really different.
Which meant I had to learn,
I basically talked to my dad constantly,
to see how he would react,
even with an eyebrow or just one word.
And I started really learning
how to have that relationship.
So I think the circumstances of my parents
created a very empathetic thing for me
which then worked well
for me as a salesman
and as a manager,
because my default in every situation.
It's why I'm a good public speaker.
I only think about the other party.
Because if you only think
about the other party,
the things that you worry
about will be there.
If you're the more valuable
entity in the relationship,
it's the leverage.
And so I think empathy is
actually fundamentally,
I would argue that Steve
Jobs' design capabilities
were far more empathetic
than anything else.
He understood the consumer's
wants and needs, intuitively.
I think a great leader is only empathetic.
So, I think that's where it comes from,
and I am very convinced,
and probably on slightly a mission
to make it something that
is talked about more.
And I think some of these softer emotional
intelligence skills, like gratitude
and empathy and kindness
have been historically
associated with women.
And I think that,
I'm an extremely alpha kind of character
and I think it's a little bit of an enigma
but I have a funny feeling I'm a preview
to something that is going to be far more
common in the future.
You know it's funny,
I often publicly answer "I don't know",
which then leads to 500
people sending me emails
that they know, and they
would love to charge
my audience $5,000 dollars
to teach 'em, right?
(chuckles)
Sorry.
I just am thinking about that.
I'm not sure, but I will say this.
The thing that I've seen work,
the closest advice I've given
to people that work for me
and my friends that has worked
but I'm not so sold that
it's building self-awareness,
but it might be a precursor.
Is creating relationships
with the people that
know you the best
that allows a safe place for
them to tell you the truth.
And this is why I think therapy is great,
couples' therapy, all
these different things
are really powerful.
It's how I mitigate with my managers.
You need to create an environment
where people can give you honest feedback.
So, in my office,
people that visit me, business associates,
other people are flabbergasted by the way
my employees talk to me.
And I'm super proud of it.
They think they're being disrespectful,
I think I've created
the right environment.
If you're comfortable
enough to tell me I suck
(laughs)
then we're on the right path, right?
So, I think it's by
if you really want to figure it out,
just tactically,
I think a hardcore two, three hour dinner
with the 15 people that you know the best,
family and friends
where you convince them,
in a week I need you to come back
and tell me the truth to every question,
and you're not gonna hurt my feelings
and I'm not gonna lash out.
If you can ever pull that off,
you need actual, real candor
and feedback because
people are ideological
and romantic of who they are or
what they are going to be.
And then that creates emotional responses.
It's why I love entrepreneurship so much,
there's nowhere to hide.
It doesn't matter who your grandpappy was.
Once you
and this is what I love so much about
organizations like this,
I genuinely believe
that people that start from a lower place
have the advantage now
in an internet world
because they lack entitlement,
and they've tasted negativity
so that they have the
stomach for adversity.
I think the abundance
in the system in America
and the way modern parenting is
around people with abundance trying to
protect from losses and failure
is not setting them up for reality
and I see it every day, so
I'm out there, talking to organizations
this week with people
that live in shelters.
I'm like, you don't see it,
it's tough being a 42 year old white man
and telling you this,
but here's the truth.
You have the advantage.
If you have the internet in your pocket,
and you're coming from adversity,
you've got a different hunger,
and a different framework
that is far more, far more powerful
for the world we now live in.
- You literally just
stole the perfect segue
which I wanted to point out over here
when you think about a lot
of the students from Build
look how many girls in the house,
women in the house, right?
(applauding)
Lots of minorities.
- [Gary] Yep.
- And I think in this
environment in this day and age,
as you kinda look at
these kids and those ones
over there, we see you.
Over there on your Insta.
(laughs)
What do you say to them?
Along those lines, you
kinda just did, right?
- You know what I really say to them is
bad news, unlike your
parents and grandparents,
who came from adversity,
you have no excuses,
'cause they didn't have the internet.
Bad news is what I tell them.
Whatever bullshit or excuses
you're gonna come up with
aren't gonna be true 'cause
the internet doesn't care
where you came from,
what's your last name,
what your gender is and
what skin tone you have.
It's an unbelievably open marketplace
for entrepreneurship.
The end.
So, what do I tell them?
Excuses out the door.
- You got this.
- You're not gonna be able to
You have to understand why.
My big thing is if anybody's ever made it
with your circumstance,
if there's ever been a person who's had
two alcoholic parents,
lived in 13 foster homes,
and went on to succeed and have happiness,
the excuse has been eliminated.
That's how I think about it.
- Perfect, thank you Gary.
We were gonna do one
more and I was gonna say,
under the age of 20 is
gonna get the privilege.
(crosstalk)
- We'll do both.
- We'll do both,
we'll do both.
- Yes, you first.
- In a society full of opportunities
for young people, when do you know
it's time to take your shot?
- [Gary] First of all, it
depends on what your shot is.
Usually the way I think
about taking a shot is
if you're not negatively
affecting anybody around you
that you care for, it's
time to take your shot.
Right?
So, I don't know how
you're defining your shot.
I often give advice that is unpopular
around the current infrastructure.
I'm the biggest fan of
all time of education.
I'm the least fan of the way
education is packaged and sold.
Right?
The answer is now.
The only thing that stops
people from taking their shot
are something very black and white
and something extremely gray.
The gray part is other people's opinions.
You're worried about
other people's opinions.
The only other thing is
if you've defined your shot as
I'm gonna open up a store
and you don't have the
money to open up the store.
But to me, you could sell in
a pop-up store for one day,
or on Shopify or Amazon for
one day before you get to that.
So you eliminate that excuse,
and as you can imagine
maybe by the tone of today's conversation,
I'm desperately trying to get everybody
into their own head and get
if I wish anything for
anybody here besides health,
it would be to be able to
be so emotionally strong
that you're able to shut out
every voice but your own.
And if your own voice
is telling you, you suck
and this and that, you
need to understand that
somebody fed that to you.
And that you need to work
and chip away at that
and change that voice.
- [Host] We have time
for one more I believe.
(audience applauds)
We'll take the claps.
- So every morning when
I'm on my Instagram,
I see one of your posts.
And, you have a different
phrase every day.
So my question is, how can you relate to
everybody in the world and motivate?
- That's awfully nice.
Honestly, I think what's happening for me
and what I would wish for so many more,
look, I have my thing.
But I do believe a lot of people here
could do a lot more good
if they didn't think about
creating, and if they
didn't overthink about
what they said, and they
just spoke about their truth.
People are like, you're
such a good speaker.
I'm like, yeah I just talk
about what I'm living.
I don't have to create
anything, there's no deck.
I only talk about very narrow things of
what I understand.
I think the thing that's
resonating and why
you'll say that to me
and why the other day
I'm at the airport, and
this 92 year old woman
came up to me and she's like,
your Instagram's the shit!
I'm like oh my God!
(audience laughs)
Is because I think the one
thing that ties that together
from that huge range is I speak my truth.
I'm not on Instagram trying
to come up with quotes
to get more likes.
I'm on Instagram because
I enjoy communicating.
And so I think the reason
I'm able to continue to
post so much is because
I'm just speaking what I'm
thinking about at that moment.
To me, I'm doing so much in my life,
that themes are popping up all the time.
I'm affected by this hour right now.
And your questions and
what you're thinking.
Inevitably, I'm going to go in the car,
and I might wait 'til my next meeting and
I may think about something
that was brought up.
How you zoned in on empathy,
that's, I know for a fact,
especially how you asked it,
that's gonna play for me quite a bit.
Or how seeing this young man again
last time in Singapore, four months later,
five months later, we see
him again and guess what?
He's still fuckin' impatient!
(laughs)
And he's listening, and he's listening
and he's listening to me,
and he's impatient!
And so I'm like, why can't
I break through to him
and everybody else on this?
And so, all these themes
will happen, right?
And so, I think I'm able to do it
because I'm just living my truth,
through and through.
And I think a lot of
people are trying to game
or get short term feelings.
People are playing for the wrong reasons.
- [Host] So, we're gonna do,
first of all, Gary, thank you so much
(applauding)
on behalf of Build,
the sponsors, everybody that's been
working hard to lead up to the event.
- I also want to give a huge
shout out to the strategy.
If the youngsters are over there,
and you put the food there,
that was fuckin' smart.
(laughs)
- That, Gary's gonna be
here for a little bit.
He's got some books, please get his book.
And Gary, we are here, obviously
we're here for the kids,
we're here for you as well.
Huge round of applause for Gary
(audience applauds)
Thank you very much.
- Thanks for having me.
(audience applauds)
(hip hop music)